it is a bit of a nightmare scenario for
Republican Threshers because of the
sheer level of opposition that Trump
Wheels out just his name is enough to
mobilize a lot of democratic support
Democrats are having a very good time
fundraising for Joe Biden at the moment
largely by talking about Trump because
if you talk about Trump you get a lot of
people pouring money in to stop him I
think Republicans the ideal scenario for
a lot of Republicans thrashes would be
Trump had pulled out the picture earlier
and said I give my full backing to a Ron
DeSantis figure that would have been the
ideal that obviously was never going to
happen and so now Republicans are having
to accept the fact that their movement
is Trump's movement and you'll notice
that a few people now fall it back in
behind him because they simply have to
um